so much has gone on over the past couple
of days how are you feeling right now
oh i mean i'm a bit overwhelmed
but i'm just trying to take it all in
and get a whole chance
and yeah obviously it's kind of
heartbreaking what happened but
i'm i'm happy so i'm at peace with it oh
that's good you know when you walked out
of that house to discover that it was a
fake eviction what was going on in your
mind what were you thinking
well i was very confused i had no idea
what was going on i know big brothers
always got something up their sleeve and
it was just another twist of course and
i was just excited
once i figured out that it was a fake
double and
i was like hey this is the opportunity
that i was praying for
to get back in that house and i was just
very excited
to get going with it yeah were you
surprised to see
tara voted out after you
oh there was no ounce of surprise in me
i knew that was happening
um i knew if given the opportunity tara
would be next 100 and i told her that
i told her keep me and you know i'll
keep you safe but
you know i knew that those other guys
maybe they had the opportunity
they'd cut her yeah you know tara told
you an awful lot of
information in the hoh room um did that
change at all the way
that you kind of maneuvered this whole
game
uh well yeah she told me a lot of
information in that hoh
i didn't really know how to take it at
the time
um i did feel betrayed by my alliance in
that moment and then just hearing about
the overall plan and how kiefer kind of
orchestrated something to
use my loyalty against me um i was just
like you know what touche hats off
like it was a great move but i was
thinking that if i get back in that host
it's going to be
an absolute hellfire so i was just fired
up in that moment and i wanted to win
really bad you know you've said this you
played a very loyal game
do you feel like you would have gone
further if you were a little bit more
cutthroat
absolutely um i would have obviously i
wouldn't have used that
pov on beth i would have used it on
myself if i was just thinking for myself
but
my entire life i've been a team player
i've always been a part of team sports
and it's always been team first i'm very
selfless
and in that moment it wasn't even a
question for me if that was a decision i
had to make to get my team to the end
that's exactly what i was going to do
yeah you know you and deshaun were close
from day one
how are you feeling about him right now
how are you feeling that he turned on
you
uh obviously i'm a bit salty but at the
end of the day i knew that he wanted to
win this game very
badly and he knew that he couldn't beat
me so
he had to get me out at any opportunity
he could so i understand the game move
obviously i really tried to play on his
emotions and his
our personal connection when it came
down to the line but
he was he was playing that cutthroat
game that i
can't play so i just have to take my
hats off to him and respect that and i
hope he does well
yeah you know with that respect still
there do you guys think you'll be
friends outside of the show at all
oh absolutely we're going to be boys for
life
we're getting a condo in toronto we're
going to get a new dog
golden doodle named chains and
and yeah we're gonna we're gonna be boys
outside of this for sure and i'm always
gonna rag on them that you know you had
to
you had to get me out because you
couldn't beat me buddy so that's that's
what it is
yeah own that own man do you have
any regrets of how you played this game
honestly morgan i have no regrets um i
think i played a good game i came in i
said i'm going to be loyal
i'm going to be trustworthy i'm going to
be true to myself which is a very
selfless genuine person in real life i
always put others before myself and i
think that that showed um throughout the
season and
yeah i mean at the end of the day the
only regret i really have
was putting kiefer on the block when i
was hoh because that was the one
um showing of loyalty that i broke
and i really broke and burnt that bridge
and i think that had i not done that
he would have been more willing to save
me the following week so
that was the one move i think kind of
ruined my game but other than that i
think i played a very stand-up game
yeah no you definitely did so look if
you had stayed in the game and it had
come down to
final two beth or ty who do you think he
would have picked
oh um i i would have picked beth i mean
i told her from the beginning that she
was my number one
and um our connection was just deeper
than the game it was something that i
truly enjoyed and i think
you know like it was just it was just my
best connection in the house and from
the very beginning i told them both that
they were my number ones
but really it was beth the whole time
and i knew that tai had other things
going on he had he had bigger plans and
i could trust beth with everything so it
would have had to be her
do you still have good feelings towards
beth
oh absolutely yeah i yeah i have a great
relationship with her
i knew that she was in a tough position
because all she heard every day was that
you know jez running your game
he's doing everything like you haven't
done anything in this game and
people were really playing on her
insecurities so i can't fault her for
that
i knew that she would have to get me out
eventually if she wanted to win
it was just who's gonna take the shot
first so i i do
really um respect and appreciate her
and i hope she does very well i mean i
did use this pov on her so i hope that
she gets far in the game and i know that
our relationship outside the house will
be extremely strong
yeah you know you definitely took your
shot to battle back into the house it
was fierce competition
tara came out on top what do you want to
see from her now that she's back in the
house
i just want to see her be confident i
mean
she's kind of counted herself out on a
couple occasions even going into that
battle back
like she was kind of talking as if she
had already lost and telling me what to
do when i got back into the house
and i had to remind her tara you have a
great chance of winning this as well
you've done a lot of things in this game
you've made big moves
and you've been on the outside the
entire game you had to face a lot of
adversity
being your age having to kind of build
these relationships with younger players
so i do have a lot of respect for tara
we didn't see eye to eye throughout the
game
but um we're always strong on a personal
level
so i do hope that she gets to the end at
this point i never thought i'd say that
but i do hope she gets to the end and if
she makes a couple more moves
she'll win the game no i love that
you're putting up the positive vibes
that's good
absolutely yeah yeah now is there anyone
now to go to maybe negative is there
anyone that you do not want to see win
the game
um i mean it's tough to say but
i mean at this point i can't i can't say
that i'd like to see braden win the game
just because
he has floated through the game um he
was on the other side of the house the
entire game he was coming after me he
was coming after my alliance even if he
says he wasn't he was a part of
alliances that were so you're guilty by
association
and i feel like he likes to run to power
a lot whoever's hoh she's their new best
friend
so it's not a game that i fully respect
but
i do love him as an individual i think
that if he does make a couple big moves
coming down the line here he does have a
case to win but from my knowledge right
now
and what i've seen i i wouldn't like him
to be representing uh big brother nine
yeah no that makes sense um you know
when you look at this whole experience
how does it feel to be part of such a
diverse season
of big brother oh it's absolutely
amazing um
i think the casting and the production
did an amazing job with this cast
it was definitely the best cast in bb
can history
uh the diversity and just bringing
everyone together
i think at one point like everyone in
the house was either like a poc
or like a female like something like
there was something so
um i think by the end we narrowed it
down that the winner of the season will
be
a a poc or a female i think that's the
case right now so it's like
that's amazing to me and i'm happy to
have been a part of it i'm just proud
especially with
all the social justice issues we went
through over the last year like this is
an
amazing representation of a canadian
broadcast so i'm really proud to be a
part of it
that's amazing and what do you hope
canada you know took away from watching
you
on this season
i mean i hope that canada just sees that
you don't always
have to backstab lie and cheat in order
to get far in life like you can just
wear your heart on your sleeve
um you can show your loyalty show that
trust and
once you're committed to to certain
people you can just ride it out with
them like that's just my
my philosophies like always having a
team and just staying true to that team
and at the end of the day
i can't regret anything because i went
out being loyal to the people i've been
loyal to since day one
and i mean it's unfortunate that they
didn't show the same loads he backs me
but
it is a game and i just stayed true to
myself the entire time so
i hope canada just sees that you can
just stay true to yourself and
everything else will work itself out
yeah all right well
to wrap things up i have to ask right
now
anyway where uh where does your jury
vote lie
oh um i think right now uh has to lie
with kiefer
if he makes it to the end he one
thousand percent has my vote
um they would be very dumb not to get
him out
sooner than later because if he makes it
they they
have to know that his resume is by far
the best so
if he's sitting in that final two i have
to give it to my captain my day one
the person that chose me number one
overall it's gotta go to kiefer
ah i love that well thank you so much
congrats on everything you know you've
gone through this show
this is not an easy experience and it's
nice to know that you can feel really
proud of what you put out there
i appreciate it so much thank you morgan